having won hearts and laughs is Hurley
unlost actor Jorge Garcia returned to
primetime on season 4 of Hawaii five-o
playing conspiracy theorist Jerry Ortega
he was bumped up to series regular
status two seasons later and his
character became an official part of the
task force in season seven you weren't a
jerk buddy but the season 10 premiere of
Hawaii five-o which aired in September
2019 saw the characters fortunes change
though Ortega had recovered from the
gunshot wound he sustained on the season
9 finale his near-death experience
prompted a reevaluation he ultimately
quit the life of major crime solving to
return to his true love conspiracy
theories specifically one involving the
US Federal Reserve in the Titanic
disaster in real life
Garcia announced that he wouldn't be
back for the rest of season 10 telling
TV Line that he was grateful for his
time on Hawaii five-o but indicating he
wouldn't be back anytime soon Hawaii
five-o had its own near-death experience
a few months later and it didn't come
out so well
turns out Hawaii five-o is run came to
an end before an 11th season and it
looks like Garcia got out of a sinking
ship ahead of everyone else but why did
he leave Hawaii five-o in the first
place bidding farewell to Jerry Ortega
was a sad moment for Jorge Garcia and
Hawaii five-o fans but fittingly for a
series set in the sunny island state the
actor didn't leave under a cloud in an
interview published the same day his
last episode of Hawaii five-o aired
Garcia told TV Line that he was thankful
for his time on the show especially
since it allowed him to head back to the
place where he filmed lost he shared I
loved getting to return to the islands
and creating a character that connected
with so many people playing Jerry was a
blast and I look forward to popping in
again to play with my TV Ohana with no
one yet aware that none of the cast
would be coming back for a dreamt about
Hawaii five-o season 11 showrunner Peter
M link of related TV Line there will
always be a place for Jorge and Jerry on
Hawaii five-o and while we obviously
wish Jorge the very best we will
sincerely miss him very much
proving there really wasn't backstage
drama behind his departure Garcia has
already returned to the linked off
universe a family of shows
masterminded by link off that overlaps
with the NCIS universe on February 18 20
2010 current MacGyver actor Henry Ian
Cusick tweeted a selfie of himself and
Garcia on the set of MacGyver a reboot
of the 1985 series of the same name with
the caption look who came out to play
the official MacGyver Twitter account
retweeted the image and announced that
Garcia would appear as Ortega on a
future episode of the show you don't
just walk away from the island life
apparently although we don't know when
Garcia's MacGyver appearance will air
his fans can catch him in a few other
projects in the meantime he's one of
many famous actors to have a cameo in
the wrong Missy the Adam Sandler
produced Netflix comedy that involves a
case of mistaken identity and another
trip to Hawaii it's not just the setting
that's familiar
Garcia plays yet another guy on a plane
in the film smells good this morning his
next role is a total departure from
airplanes but not Islands the drama
picked nobody knows I'm here hits
Netflix on June 24th and stars Garcia as
a shy singer whose attempt to hide from
the world on a remote Chile an island is
ruined when a video of him singing goes
viral on YouTube the movie was part of
the 2020 Tribeca Film Festival in an
Instagram post Garcia wrote I'm really
proud of this movie I hope you all check
it out even when he's not on our screens
Garcia is providing quality
entertainment to the masses those
missing Garcia's voice as much as they
miss his face can check out his
bi-weekly podcast
cai-you podcast in which he and co-host
Ralph Apple discussed giant monsters and
movies check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]